and so as we get into this video about
Jason Todd what we're going to be doing
is we're going to be splitting this
video up into three segments the first
part of the video is going to focus on
the pre-crisis on Infinite Earths origin
and stories of Jason Todd the second
part is going to focus on the
post-crisis Jason Todd and the third
part is going to focus on the new 52
so Jason's hot introduction to us and DC
Comics actually comes as part of a
six-part crossover between Batman and
Detective Comics now with Detective
Comics he appeared in Detective Comics
issues number 524 through 526 and with
Batman vol 1 it was issues 357 to 359
and the way the jason todd has given to
us is actually really interesting here
he was initially created by Jerry Conway
and Don Newton and les Daniel's a
comic-book historian when he was writing
about this in his book Batman the
complete history what he tells us is
that when Dick Grayson had become Robin
he had been Robin for so long the
character Robin had basically become an
intrinsic part of the Batman continuity
and so as a result with DC experimenting
with moving Dick Grayson away having did
Grayson become his own superhero who
would later on become Nightwing DC was
trying to find a way to basically bring
back the concept of Robin to provide
this element that had been lacking in
Batman comics and ultimately began to I
guess contribute to the decline in
readership of Batman comics and so with
the arrival of Jason Todd what we found
was that initially DC DC fans absolutely
hated him and the reason for this is
because the origins of Jason Todd as are
given to us are almost identical to the
origins of Dick Grayson
Dick Grayson of course as we discussed
in our video was the son of acrobats the
flying Grayson's who were killed when
the circus owner refused to pay
protection money to a local mob boss
Jason Todd was almost the exact same way
the only difference here was that Killer
Croc was initially given to us as the
person that had killed Jason Todd's
parents which coincidentally this
actually includes the first appearance
of Killer Croc in Batman comics but the
fact remains that because it appeared to
DC fans that DC was trying to make a
mirror image of Dick Grayson in the form
of Jason Todd and then throw it on to DC
fans they despised him again almost upon
his initial creation now over time over
the course of the next few years what we
found was that Dick Grayson I'm sorry
the Jason table would develop a fan base
of sorts but that ultimately we would
see this fan base split down the middle
and see just how divided the fan base
was when it came to Jason Todd in terms
of whether or not he should live or he
should die when we get to the story of
the death and the family but what we do
here is we begin a transition into the
post-crisis
world of Dick Grayson I'm sorry of Jason
Todd the reason being because this is
when we start to see Jason Todd really
step into his own really kind of become
more of an interesting character and
eventually we'll see this begin unfold
largely when we get into the new 52 era
and even some of the events before the
new 52 where we look at him undertaking
the role of the Red Hood so as we know
with 1985 we saw the crisis on Infinite
Earths in the DC continuity then what DC
was basically doing with the crisis on
Infinite Earths as they were looking at
their various lineups various characters
then they were trying to find a way to
revamp them in a way that would make
them more appealing to comic-book
readers and so what we found was that
with his introduction post crisis that
what they had done is they had gone back
and they had said the Killer Croc was
not the person that had murdered his
parents that instead his parents were
murdered by two-faced and to a degree
this found some residence among comic
book fans to a degree people were sort
of beginning to get on board with Jason
Todd because now what they saw DC doing
was listening to the fans and saying
okay they're this original version of
Jason Todd isn't successful then let's
try this new one and see how it works
out and this is when we start to see the
fan base of Jason Todd grow a little bit
but ultimately the vocal people were
still there the vocal concept of Jason
Todd not being well-received was still
there and so what do you see did is in
1988 they gave us the death in the
family not what they also did here is
they basically left it to the fans to
decide whether or not Jason Jason Todd
should live or die this is one of the
most popular elements of Jason Todd's
continuity what DC did is they set up a
1 900 number and they gave fans the
opportunity to call in and to decide
whether or not Jason Todd should live or
die and by a very slim margin of about a
hundred votes or so which ended up being
5343 in support of Jason Todd dying and
five thousand two hundred and
seventy-one against Jason Todd dying
what we found was that DC killed Jason
Todd off and again this was a massive
moment in the history of DC continuity
and the reason why was because this
again basically began to solidify the
concept in comic books of this
triumvirate of sources to say in the
realm of comic books there were only
three characters that stay dead the
versus Uncle Ben the second is Bucky
Barnes and the third is Jason Todd and
so what we would find going forward with
this post-crisis continuity is that
Jason Todd would remain absent from DC
Comics for almost 15 years we would
never actually see him in any real
former fashion with the exception of
flashbacks but all this changed around
2000 or so when we saw the introduction
of a storyline called hush now with Jeff
Loeb and Jim Lee's hush this of course
was a story that was based on a villain
whose identity hadn't been revealed the
beginning of the story but who was
basically I guess bringing all the
villains of that man together for the
purpose of launching this sort of
psychological and physical warfare
against Batman but what we saw was that
as a stories began to progress as a
series continue to move forward but
periodically there would be these hints
and drops from time to time of Jason
Todd and so in issue number 617 which
came out in 2003 again 15 years after
death and the family where Jason Todd
had been killed we had seen a scenario
whereby Jason Todd had held the new
version of robbing Tim Drake hostage and
was preparing to kill him in front of
Batman now this revelation to comic book
fans to DC fans was mind-blowing this
was huge one of the biggest moments in
the history of Batman and DC continuity
overall and the reason for this is
because again this was basically the
possibility existing that DC would bring
back Jason Todd this was the possibility
existing that all those people who grew
up with Jason Todd and then had to watch
him die could see the character come
back again but what we found was that in
an interview with News Rama that Jeff
Lowe had come out and said that he had
no real intention of bringing back Jason
Todd the reason being because he had
always felt that Jason Todd dying was
really this motivation to keep Batman
doing what it was that he was doing they
kept giving Batman this motivation to
constantly fight crime that the loss of
his parents was one of the greatest
losses of his experience but the loss of
Jason Todd was really his biggest
failure here but because of the fan
reaction to Jason Todd because so many
fans were at
we excited to see the possibility of
Jason Todd returning DC didn't really
have a choice here you see will I kind
of had their hand force in this
situation and so ultimately what we saw
was that Jason Todd would returned to DC
Comics under the continuity or under the
story of a six-part limited series
called Batman under the Red Hood now
where Batman under the Red Hood
basically gave us this story whereby
Jason Todd had returned to Gotham City
operating under the mantle of the Red
Hood what we're actually going to do is
we're going to sidestep this for a
second and we're going to jump to 2010
when the reason we're going to jump to
2010 is because what Judd Winick had
done is he had given us a story called
Red Hood The Lost days and what this did
is it basically gave us how it was
things to progress it told us what
happened between the time that Jason
Todd had basically been killed during
death in the family and how it was that
he had come back to life or how it was
he had basically undertaken this mantle
now initially the story doesn't really
tell us how it was he had come back to
life that's actually covered in Batman
annual number 25 and with Batman annual
number 25 what's told to us is that when
superboy-prime
was trying to punch his way out of the
Paradise dimension a ramification of
this or a ripple effect of this was that
Jason Todd was simply just revived DC
doesn't really tell us why DC doesn't
really tell us how this happened they
don't tell us how it was and this
happened in the first place it simply
just takes place it's just their way of
kind of shoehorning in why it is that
Jason Todd had returned to life but
again going back into Red Hood The Lost
days what we find is that once Jason
Todd begins to wake up once he basically
digs himself out of his grave this story
picks up with him when Talia al Ghul
becomes aware of the fact that Jason
Todd is alive now again Jason Todd is
not the biological child of Talia al
Ghul but Talia al Ghul's rationale at
least as far as it's drawn out by her
father is that if she is able to
basically rehabilitate Jason Todd who at
this moment is really more of in a
comatose state or kind of a walking
zombie than anything else that if she
rehabilitates him and takes him back to
that man
that Batman will probably love her and
so what happens is that she basically
takes Jason Todd back to the home back
to her home and she begins to I guess
again try to rehabilitate him try to get
him back and of functioning normally and
so ultimately as time begins to progress
Jason Todd sort of begins to come to to
a degree but ultimately this is really
more of a circumstance where Jason Todd
is a I guess would be a victim of the
Lazarus pits what I mean by that is as
far as we know with the Lazarus pits of
Rachel Ghul that when someone is put
into the lazarus pit they are
effectively healed of any wounds and
they are granted and I guess an
extension to their existing life but a
side effect of this is that they simply
become mad and so this is what appears
to have happened with Jason Todd that
with Talia al Ghul unable to effectively
bring him out of this comatose state
Beth she throws him into the lazarus pit
and as a result he begins to sort of
breathe anew as at least as far as Jason
Todd describes it it's like waking up
out of a dream but instead of being
rational he's more of a madman now he's
not necessarily insane on the level of
the Joker but at this point in time his
mindset is to basically kill Batman and
the reason why is because from the red
hoods perspective from Jason Todd's
perspective if Batman truly cared about
him Batman would have killed the Joker
in retaliation for the Joker killing
Jason Todd but man hadn't done that not
only had Batman not done that Batman had
undertaken another Robin he had
undertaken Tim Drake and so from Jason
Todd's perspective it seemed as though
Batman has simply just moved forward and
didn't really care that much about Jason
Todd at all and so again under this the
story of the Lost years I'm sorry the
last days what we find is that we learn
Jason Todd was effectively sort of I
maybe I guess maybe stalled by Talia al
Ghul but the way that she had done this
was by making him a deadlier person
which seems a little strange but she had
basically sent him to various tutors
people that taught him and capitalized
on the lessons he had learned from Bruce
Wayne now they didn't know that he was
Jason Todd and that he was he was taught
by Bruce Wayne all they knew was that he
had a prodigious set of skills in terms
of basic chemistry in terms of physical
combat and weapons use what these
mentors did was
banned on those capabilities joining
Jason Todd into one of the foremost
assassins in the world but over the
course of the story what we also found
was that Jason Todd began to realize
that a lot of these mentors were
involved in some rather unsavory acts
that one of the mentors that taught him
I guess enhanced hand-to-hand combat
tactics was involved in in the child sex
slave ring what we also found was that
one of the other individuals who had
taught him how to make bombs was tied at
with the Russian mob and their intention
was to basically divert the intelligence
agencies of Britain away from the
Russian mob by detonating several bombs
over I guess around London and then
blaming it on Arabic extremists these
are the kinds of schemes that his his
mentors had in store for themselves and
so what Jason Todd began to do was
effectively learn what he needed to
learn and then kill off these mentors
and so ultimately as time progressed he
began to develop this mindset whereby he
lost interest in killing Batman it
wasn't necessarily the drive to kill
Batman and once Talia al Ghul had asked
him what his motive was what it is he
wanted to achieve by travelling back to
Gotham he said he really wasn't quite
sure here
and so what Talia al Ghul said is that
he can be a better Batman than Bruce
Wayne that his motivation should be to
travel back to Gotham City to usurp the
role of Batman from Bruce Wayne and then
effectively take over that role for
himself which we'll see begin to kind of
take shape to a degree with the battle
for the cowl now the battle for the cowl
was a short-lived series as far as Jason
Todd was concerned all we had found here
was that Jason Todd had arrived in
Gotham heat adopted the role or tried to
adopt the role of Batman and was almost
immediately subdued by Dick Grayson by
Nightwing and as a result Jason Todd
began to move away from this ideology
but all this really began to also
coincide with the new 52 and so this was
really all just kind of rushed together
kind of packed together very very
tightly the stories were put together so
fast it really wasn't a whole lot of
time for us to think as readers or even
for DC to effectively closed out the
continuity properly and so what we found
was that with the new 52 reboot 'never
ething that we step into a new era of
Jason Todd whereby Jason Todd is a
member of the
called the Red Hood and The Outlaws now
with the new 52 DC came back and changed
a lot of things when it came to Jason
Todd not only that they actually
streamlined and simplified a lot of
things the initial skepticism of this
really sort of came to an end with death
of the family and of course we'll get
into that as we continue with our
stories and Batman but ultimately with
new 52 we saw Jason Todd stepping into
this new role of being a character who
didn't undergo training with regards to
a multitude of different mentors but
instead was trained by a group called
the all cast we learned that instead of
him coming back to life as a result of
superboy-prime trying to punch his way
out of the Paradise dimension that
instead his body was simply taken by
Talia al Ghul and thrown into the
Lazarus pits and so again this was just
a way for DC to come back and to
simplify everything regarding Jason Todd
to basically take all this pre-crisis
and post-crisis continuity and to wrap
it all up and they make it very easy for
those who are getting into DC Comics
poster I guess during new 52 you so
basically look at the character of Jason
Todd and to see a very simplified
version but again not getting too deep
into the new 52 here because we're going
to be talking about a lot of these
stories with regards to our build up to
convergence and our discussion on the
Batman continuity what we know is that
once convergence comes to an end the Red
Hood in the outlaws is going to be one
of the stories that's going to be
canceled now we don't know if DC is
going to get rid of a Red Hood entirely
although that's highly unlikely what we
do know is that Red Hood will most
likely be undergoing another role here
you'll be playing some different kind of
position with regards to his placement
in the DC continuity but again this is
all just sort of speculation here 100%
sure about a lot of this stuff with that
being said we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end I know this
was a rough one Jason Todd was really
kind of a difficult character to get
done but I hope you guys enjoyed it if
you did let me know and I will catch you
guys later peace be sure to follow me on
Twitter there you can keep up with all
the updates from comics explained and
talk to me directly